today we are cracking down on the
massage parlors here and we know we are
sending in our very own Travis Junior
undercover with these high-tech glasses
which have a very small camera he will
infiltrate the massage parlor try to get
them to perform the sex act on him and
then we will swoop in and start making
arrests he's in he's in you in my city
you want the full everything you got
okay what do we do here it's my first
time in one of these places you like to
take off your clothes you go right to
the Super Deluxe now I don't know if
there's some kind of special
[Music]
[Laughter]
good it's great
and now happy ending oh it's a bit of
all not so much big so I'm supposed to
[Music]
[Applause]
bring Lisa you know I don't think the
cops will be coming again anytime soon
[Music]